[Music]
what's up everybody Lord sovereign here
for the low iron Lords podcast Lords of
gaming that net and we're out here at
the THQ Nordic booth that's outside of
the Convention Center we have the the
young wolf footage of the remake the
brand-new remake of all remaster should
I say of Destroy All Humans it's looking
pretty good
anybody who remembers this game on the
OG xbox it's kind of like turning a
area51 on its head and the aliens are
coming down to take care of business and
and take care of the human race we have
Lord addict decimating a farm this is
this is a human murder simulator as you
see him scorching scorching the Earth
destroying rows upon rows of maze
how do we get back to the TV you need
that you need the land in the land and
wreak havoc on the ground
oh whoa okay it's just a part of the
demo the Attic to try to write your name
fry right lord addict scorching the game
does look very pretty though even in
this pre-alpha state the game looks
beautiful and no jokes aside like
destroy humans is a very fun game
especially the first one so for them to
go back to it I think it's fun is
interesting it's basically I mean this
is THQ Nordics bag like really do I
think the next books over we also have
the new Darksiders like RTS
no I definitely got nineties earlier
than that yeah it's like Oh wasn't it
bass like in the 50s or something like
that
look at these realistic character models
amazing eyebrows on fleek
storytelling
there we go check these out Oh
ex-girlfriends like this use it up
little dudes that used to read they have
[Music]
- biddies to wreak havoc going crazy now
I also see you can abduct people oh
there go stay go get your abduction on
now I want you to take it back to the
spaceship the engine though I'm not
gonna knock off fun destroy all humans
literally hey I only hit me humans ain't
the smartest dogs that dude is shotgun
or grandpa or - Adi got us got to get it
together a real slow on the trigger with
this guy we know a decayed disco they
should let you get your abduction on
yes could you tell us the details its
unlock the probe oh my god it's not
available for the demo
thankfully the children have been spared
this these details 54 seconds running
roughshod oh it's flashing it's getting
crazy
they will go today Destroy All Humans th
cute Nordic you know in all honesty the
game looks great if you love the
original it's great to see it in this
form back again the original was the
best one so I'm actually kind of excited
to play this actually it looks really
fun I ain't girlfriend what does that
add a drag this over and harassed us
it looks very fun shout the Lord addict
for this is exclusive so by lord egg put
it on home put the camera everybody know
it came from him
[Music]